hello I'm Dakota Johnson hi there Jeff
Bridges yeah and this is a wired
autocomplete interview my leg off is
Dakota Johnson related to meryl streep
know that real that's it yeah that's
people think that is Dakota Johnson in
Fifty Shades freed yes should there be
like a coal in there you'd think that
what goes automatically that would be
all right that's what I want to see that
way I don't think you did oh yeah please
don't use Dakota Johnson nominated for a
golden oak or a Golden Globe no maybe
use Dakota Johnson Dakota Fanning yes oh
my god I think I did I was in Dakota
Fanning's first film I think about five
years ago it's movie the door in the
floor yeah I was with her I was with her
a couple weeks ago yes she's amazing she
I'm not Dakota Fanning is Dakota Johnson
in Twilight no Dakota Fanning is in
Twilight it's confusing you know these
Hollywood states who is Jeff Bridges mom
Oh Dorothy bridges my mom yeah wonderful
birds who sang for Jeff Bridges in crazy
well that's easy what I did I sang for
Jeffrey you did
Wow did he no no I don't think he did
who didn't want to upset him who does
Jeff Bridges play in only the brave I
played Dwayne Stein break the fire chief
there
Arizona and he was on the side wonderful
guy cool
who does Jeff Bridges look like I've
signed a Kurt Russell photograph if
people say Kurt yeah yeah yeah yeah Oh
Nick Nolte somebody said you guys sign
that for you did you sign McNulty yeah
what color is the code of Johnson's hair
it's beautiful what do you call that
it's have an Auburn thing with a little
blonde in it is beautifully I'm a
natural blonde actually really hmm
what is the coded Johnson doing these
days I'm curious about that I've been
riding my horse a lot you English or you
Joe do you want to do the hi thing I
really want it to remain a nice thing
for me yes yes that is very wise what TV
show Dakota Johnson was here what the TV
show Johnson was in I was on the TV show
called Ben and Kate mmm a long time yeah
yeah what does the coded Johnson's
tattoo say well which one I don't know
which one they're talking about yeah
yeah be more specific
yeah what was the Conan Johnson first
movie first movie went crazy and Alabama
good experience my stepdad directed it
and my mom played my mom so it was just
like home what breed is Dakota Johnson's
dog a Jack Russell Terrier schnauzer
mixture of heaven is Jeff Bridges in a
band I am yeah we're in the abiders cool
do you abide we abide in the land of no
abiding is Jeff Bridges related to
lawyer
I am the son the son of Seto is jeff
bridges related to kris kristofferson
oh no but whenever we see each other
we've met have we gotta play brothers
sometimes that's a great idea is jeff
bridges the dude well I played the dude
[Music]
you are yeah you think so I ain't got
some bees in me somewhere a little bit
yeah
where is Dakota Johnson now right now
I'm at the Roosevelt Hotel with you do
you think you are where is Dakota
Johnson from I grew up between Los
Angeles and Colorado where did Dakota
Johnson go to school I went to high
school at new roads High School Santa
Monica we would be like barefoot and
blue hair in the yard listening to music
while maybe doing some schoolwork where
is Jeff Bridges from la hey la boy where
is Jeff Bridges today uh the Roosevelt
Hotel
where did Jeff Bridges grow up LA was
Jeff Bridges in the military that was in
the Coast Guard Reserve I was in there
for seven years
how old were you 19 20 something like
that Wow our Jeff Bridges and John
Goodman friends yes I don't see him as
much as I like to bow yeah I consider my
friend I learned today that Jeff Bridges
was in the Coast Guard
yeah very good and we got to play in
this movie you know bad times Del Rio
think I said a couple of words new but
no yeah not caring us but we will go do
it yeah you didn't say anything to me in
the whole movie yes idea what I said oh
I don't know you didn't say